mais d'abord ce devait être une banale
séance de piscine 19 élèves du collège
racan anna villeroy ont été intoxiqués
au chlore cet après midi les faits se
sont déroulés en sarthe dans une piscine
située à quelques kilomètres
d'importants moyens de secours ont été
mobilisés les précisions d'audrey
shopping champigny avec paul boyer ce
matin une classe de 6e du collège racan
de neuvy le roi se rend à la piscine
dans la commune voisine
à château du loir mais rapidement le
cours de ps tourne court
plusieurs enfants se sentent mal
visiblement incommodé par le chlore
l'enseignant est le maître nageur les
fonds alors sortir de l'eau retour au
collège prévenu les secours arrivent sur
place et prennent en charge les 19
élèves donc les symptômes
essentiellement c'est des maux de gorge
d'un outil pharyngite quelques maux de
tête
un peu de tout des nausées voilà tout ce
qu'il y avait et un petit peu aussi
d'irritation cutanée une intoxication au
chlore sans gravité tous les élèves sont
conscients et leur état ne soulève pas
d'inquiétude pour les médecins du samu
et des pompiers
la classe de 19 y avait cet enfant qui
était indemne qui avait pas de signes et
les autres et bien certains ont eu un
petit peu d'oxygène un peu de parties de
paracétamol pour ceux qui avaient des
maux de tête et ils vont bénéficier
d'une surveillance avec un scope
tous sont rentrés chez eux en fin de
journée avec une fiche de surveillance
médicale pour le week end